>> Harold: STRATEGIZING HOW TO
FIX ALL THE WORLD'S PROBLEMS.
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S CLIMATE CZAR,
FORMER SECRETARY OF STATE JOHN
KERRY, BOASTING ABOUT A PLAN TO
SAVE OUR PLANET.
>> IT'S PRETTY EXTRAORDINARY
THAT WE, A SELECT GROUP OF HUMAN
BEINGS, BECAUSE OF WHATEVER
TOUCHED US AT SOME POINT IN OUR
LIVES, ARE ABLE TO SIT IN A ROOM
AND COME TOGETHER AND ACTUALLY
TALK ABOUT SAVING THE PLANET.
I MEAN, IT'S SO ALMOST
EXTRATERRESTRIAL TO THINK ABOUT,
QUOTE, SAVING THE PLANET.
IF YOU SAID THAT TO MOST PEOPLE,
MOST PEOPLE THEY THINK YOU'RE A
CRAZY TREE-HUGGING LEFTY
LIBERAL, DO-GOODER, WHATEVER.
>> Harold: AND FORMER VICE
PRESIDENT AL GORE PAINTING A
RATHER DISMAL PICTURE OF WHAT
POLLUTION IS DOING TO MOTHER
EARTH.
>> THAT'S WHAT'S BOILING THE
OCEAN, CREATING ATMOSPHERIC
RIVERS, THE RAIN BOMBS, SUCKING
THE MOISTURE OUT OF THE LAND,
CREATING THE DROUGHTS AND
MELTING THE ICE, RAISING THE SEA
LEVEL, CLIMATE REFUGEES, 1 BILL
IN THIS CENTURY, WE HAVE TO ACT!
>> Harold: THE VICE PRESIDENT
HAS BEEN MOVED BY THIS ISSUE FOR
A LONG TIME.
IS THIS JUST A BUNCH OF RICH
PEOPLE?
>> Dana: 140,000 PRIVATE PLANES
SHOWED UP FOR THIS MEETING.
I DON'T KNOW IF THEY ATTEND THE
AL GORE'S ELECTTURE THERE.
AS TO WHAT JOHN KERRY SAID, HE
SAID ISN'T IT AMAZING THAT -- WE
WERE TOUCHED.
WE ARE THE SPECIAL ONES.
WE ARE THE ONES WHO ARE GOING --
WE GET TO SIT IN A ROOM AND TALK
ABOUT SAVING THE PLANET.
WHAT ABOUT DOING SOMETHING TO
SAVE THE PLANET?
WHAT ABOUT THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
NOT TOUCHED LIKE JOHN KERRY, WHO
MIGHT TO LIVE IN NAIROBI, IN THE
CONGO, MAYBE PLACES IN AFRICA,
FOR EXAMPLE, WHERE THEY'VE BEEN
DENIED THE ABILITY TO DEVELOP
RESOURCES SO THEY CAN HAVE THEIR
OWN ENERGY AND ELECTRICITY AND
BECOME MORE INDEPENDENT, WHICH
COULD LEAD TO MORE INNOVATIONS,
SO WE COULD GET TO SOMETHING
LIKE FUSION SOONER AND ALL DO
SOMETHING GOOD FOR THE PLANET ON
THAT POINT.
HERE'S THE THING, ALSO, THEY
WANT TO FOCUS ON CLIMATE CHANGE,
BUT DON'T TALK ABOUT CHINA.
THE CHINA ENERGY INVESTMENT
GROUP, THAT IS THE MAIN ENTITY
THAT'S EXPANDING USE OF COAL
THERE.
WHY WOULDN'T THEY TALK ABOUT IT
THERE?
GUESS WHAT I FOUND OUT.
THEY'RE A SPONSOR OF DAVOS.
>> Jeanine: OF COURSE.
>> Harold: JUDGE, YOU SOUND
READY.
>> Jeanine: CHINA IS EVERYWHERE.
CHINA IS IN THE UNIVERSITIES.
CHINA IS IN THE COLLEGES.
I MEAN, IT'S IN THE GOVERNMENT.
WE SHOULDN'T BE SURPRISED.
IT'S IN SPORTS.
IT'S IN MOVIES.
WE ARE A SELECT GROUP OF HUMAN
BEINGS.
IMAGINE, WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
PLANET.
THE REST OF THE PEOPLE ARE JUST
RUBES.
THEY DON'T KNOW ANYTHING.
THERE'S SUCH A CONDESCENDING
KIND OF ARROGANCE, THEY
PONTIFICATE ABOUT THEMSELVES,
AND THE TRUTH IS THEY'RE
SPENDING OUR TAX DOLLARS.
WE'RE WORKING AND THEY'RE
SPENDING OUR MONEY.
WE'VE ALREADY SPENT A TRILLION
DOLLARS FOR RENEWABLE ENERGY.
IT'S THE RICHEST COUNTRIES THAT
HAVE THE LOWEST CARBON
EMISSIONS, OTHER THAN, CHINA,
WHICH IS NOT THE RICHEST YET.
BUT THE MONEY THAT'S BEING SPENT
MONEY, MONEY, MONEY -- IS MONEY
THAT THE UNITED STATES IS GIVING
TO OTHER GOVERNMENTS.
SO THEY TAX US, CALL US RUBES,
AND THEN RUN AROUND IN THEIR
PRIVATE PLANES.
>> Harold: GREG, IN THE
GREENROOM, YOU TOLD ME, WHAT DO
YOU THINK ABOUT THIS SPEECH BY
VICE PRESIDENT GORE?
>> Greg: WELL, I AGREE WITH YOU
COMPLETELY.
IT WAS AN ABSOLUTE TOTAL
EMBARRASSMENT.
I'M GLAD YOU SAID THAT.
[LAUGHTER]
YOU LOOK BACK IN THE SHOW,
YOU'LL FIND IT THERE.
WHY IS IT -- YOU LOOK AT AL
GORE, YOU LOOK AT JOHN KERRY.
WHY ARE THE PEOPLE SO CONCERNED
BY THE HEALTH OF THE PLANET LOOK
SO UNHEALTHY.
WHY DO THEY LOOK SO SICK?
I MEAN, THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT
SUCKING THE MOISTURE OUT OF THE
EARTH.
THAT GUY LOOKS LIKE HE NEEDS
WATERING, RIGHT?
HE'S GOT THE COMPLEXION OF A
DELAPIDATED TUMBLEWEED.
THEY'RE ALL DRIFTWOOD, ALL COME
TOGETHER FOR ONE YEAR, AND PAT
EACH OTHER ON THEIR SPLINTERED
BACKS.
I'LL TELL YOU WHAT -- YOU KNOW
WHAT -- I FORGOT WHAT I WAS
GOING TO SAY.
STELTER IS THERE, TALKING ABOUT
DISINFORMATION.
ISN'T IT AMAZING?
WHAT'S HE GOING TO TALK ABOUT
NEXT?
HOW TO GET WASHBOARD ABS.
SERIOUSLY.
I'M NOT INVITED TO THESE THINGS,
BECAUSE IF YOU GO THERE WITH
SOLUTION THEY CAN'T HAVE THEIR
FUN ANYMORE.
THE CLIMATE CHANGE IS GREAT,
BECAUSE EVERY YEAR THAT'S ALWAYS
THE PROBLEM.
YOU CAN STILL HAVE YOUR DAVOS
PARTY, STILL FLY IN, AND IT WILL
NEVER BE SOLVED.
>> Harold: THE OIL COMPANIES'
CEOs ARE IN DEMAND AT THIS
CONFERENCE FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
A LONG TIME.
>> Jesse: IS THAT RIGHT?
>> Harold: YEAH.
>> Jesse: I'M GLAD IS TALKING
ABOUT PEOPLE'S PHYSICAL
APPEARANCES.
FULL BUSH BEAT THESE TWO GUYS,
KERRY AND GORE, THEY'RE LOSERS,
AND THEY KNOW IT, AND NOW THEY
HAVE TO BE SOMEONE ELSE'S
SAVIOR.
IF YOU'RE AL GORE, HAVE TO
CREATE A TERM CALLED A RAIN BOMB
TO CONVINCE ME TO GIVE UP MONEY
TO SAVE THE WORLD, THAT'S NOT
DOING IT.
BOILING THE OCEANS?
TALK ABOUT IT NORMALLY, AND
MAYBE I'LL BE MORE OPEN-MINDED.
A LITTLE ADVICE FOR JOHN KERRY.
YOU DON'T SAY YOU'RE SAVING THE
WORLD.